el acuerdo su oficial el partido
socialista francés ratificó una alianza
de coalición de izquierdas que espera
desafiar al presidente emmanuel manjón
en las elecciones parlamentarias de
junio tras horas de debates a veces
censos una amplia mayoría de los
miembros del consejo votaron a favor
vamos a tener que avanzar a partir de
ahora jean-luc mélenchon ha asumido una
gran responsabilidad de esta noche ahora
es la única esperanza para la izquierda
y los ecologistas
ecologistas jean-luc mélenchon que ha
perdido en la primera vuelta de las
presidenciales de abril busca la mayoría
de los diputados los socialistas en los
verdes los comunistas y el partido la
francia insumisa de milán son
calificaron el acuerdo como histórico
pero no todo el mundo está satisfecho
aún con divisiones en el seno del
partido socialista y socialista soy
socialista y el liderazgo ligado a la
insumisa no cambiará es el enemigo del
socialismo el ex presidente francés
françois hollande también ha manifestado
su firme oposición al acuerdo al igual
que las elecciones en ciales los
comicios legislativos en las 577
circunscripciones de francia funcionan
con un sistema de dos vueltas lo que
significa que las alianzas ofrecen unas
mejores posibilidades de llegar a la
segunda ronda la cohabitación forzada
entre maicon y mélenchon sería la
primera en dos décadas aunque los
expertos ven ese escenario como poco
probable
[Aplausos]